[Music]
i'm exhausted
barely breathing
[Music]
me
[Music]
it's amazing so amazing
so amazing so amazing
we did it we're live hello everyone hi
welcome
i want to make sure it's working on
twitch seems to be on
youtube
cool success hello everyone i'm alana
welcome to my stream um i thought we'd
play some god of war on ps5 today
because i'm very
excited that it is out
no not that it wasn't already out but
got an update
it's a free patch um to make things
prettier and i'm excited to see it
do you want to say from the jump for
disclosure reasons i do work
at santa monica studio uh this is not a
sponsored stream or anything like that i
just happen to work there and i'm
streaming this
in my own time because i love this game
independently
of my job and also that i cannot talk to
you about it
or any of the development process if you
have any questions please direct them to
the official channels
um if you would like to to know about
the ps5 update there is a press release
on the blog um
i also i'm not ready to play a game like
this yet if i'm being completely honest
my hands are still a bit messed up
they're not as bad as as this makes it
look i i i can totally survive without
having them wrapped but i have them
wrapped right now
um just to add extra padding for the
controller so it doesn't hurt me too
much
but this isn't gonna go well it's gonna
suck it's gonna hurt
so yeah just uh yeah
um i am working full time for santa
monica studio yes i do work full-time
hours doing a little stream after work
so that's what this is
thank you for the compliment on the
thumbnail i
really thought it was great i was very
fond of it
um all right i
am going to
any minute now i promise kratos i'll be
with you in a second but
just a second it's amazing
stupid my monitor is just being a jerk
there we go come on buddy there you go
and then let's do this
and then and then and then
just uh what is it
that and then that is what i'm trying to
do haha success
alrighty
cool um so yeah i'm a really big fan of
this game it was my game of the year the
year it came out
which was very controversial people were
really upset with me for not saying that
it was red dead
and um you know
don't they will play it because it's
great good time yeah
you ever just beat the living
[ __ ] out of a tree just
in your spare time anyone else ever do
that
because
every time i've ever knocked a tree down
it's with that exact amount of fury
you go go hard and go home ladies and
gentlemen oh thank you to whoever read
it i appreciate that
thanks it probably would be good therapy
i've never like
hit things because i don't really have a
temper
[Music]
um but i'm sure in some points it would
be very enjoyable
like if you're a person who has anger
problems just to beat the crap out of
something with an axe would probably be
great
uh yes i am playing on ps5
the ps5 uh patch slash
update
that's how i was before i started the
stream putting my hand bandages on
furious
we love you though buddy we love you
i mean this game was beautiful anyway
but i do feel like this also looks very
nice i'm actually not playing on a 4k
monitor
um still want me to tie to the boat
i'm excited to see parts that are more
colorful
you know probably not going to be
streaming for very long
um go skill just because i do think this
game is going to hurt my hands pretty
bad
and i don't want to screw it up i don't
wanna
i don't know i'm in this weird position
where you know
my hands are really weak and i keep
wondering should i push it and make them
hurt
and will that help or should i keep
cradling them and being careful
i feel like right now they're still a
little bit too sore that pushing is not
the right idea but
it is a thing that weighs on me
father did something change
the force feels different
everything is different boy try not to
dwell on it
sick hand breaky do they call it that in
america
can you pull a e break i think is what
they call it
exactly ihon has slapped some trees
uh my last call was a honda
called an acura in america it was an
integra
pull your e-brake
the snow does look really beautiful and
the lighting here is super nice
but bias in that
will i play the new mario game probably
uh alison look you know i'm an extremely
biased source
by how god of war is if you've never
played it but i think this game is
absolutely fantastic
but you know you should ask anyone but
me
that question
that was the last
corey barlog what kind of name is that
sounds like an idiot
[Music]
[Music]
oh there do i see my mother
i've never lit candles like that you
know do i see
my father which is i just want to be
clear to all of you
that what i was just thinking in my head
could not be more different to what i
decided to say out loud
what i was thinking in my head was like
any representation
of parents dying in any medium hits me
really hard i'm so terrified of anything
happening to my parents which naturally
of course it will
that's life but it haunts me um
the only thing i have any kind of
anxiety about but then the thing i said
out loud was
probably burn yourself if you actually
tried to light a kettle with the kettle
she's ready
[Music]
i finished this game in like five days
the first time that i played it
might have been less might have been
like three
when this game came out
was i was in la for one of my like first
interviews with um fun house it was
before it came out because i got it
early
um
[Music]
and i took a playstation to la to the
hotel or no i bought i borrowed one
because i got the code and i borrowed
one from fun house
took it to the hotel after working in
funhouse
really came full circle on all that
[Music]
[Music]
the music is beautiful
[Music]
uh yoho duelist i have beaten this game
already
yes um this is on ps5
indeed i don't really want to make any
comment
on any of my perceptions of the
performance or any of that at all or any
details like that go to the press
release if you want to um
check that stuff out sorry
did i like red dead too i did yeah
there's a lot that i really liked about
red dead too squeeze
this knife it was hers
now it is yours
he couldn't be more different to my dad
i have this like
bubbly little softie of a father
what are we hunting you are hunting deer
uh other than god of war which is my
favorite game of all time god war is not
my favorite game of all time
um my favorite game ever is deadly
prevention
this way
father you why are we doing this now
just i need to know
that muscle you know then we leave for
the mountain
like how much calories got eaten a day
what my gosh
what did you find tracks not deer though
i'll keep looking
oh which god of war is my favorite uh
this one would be my favorite god of war
game i did really like god of war too
um which i swear i'm not saying because
of
more corey yeah but they're too round
it could be a while board good uh i
really liked all of them forsaken is the
truth but you
i i feel like i really am a terrible
person to um
to to ask this question you know i
literally work with the students
would i ever get a deadly premonition
tattoo uh eli elijah
i actually have one dear drugs they're
fresh
a deadly premonition tattoo
and two pokemon tattoos
i have a yoshi got a couple video
tattoos
sorry you are hunting deer not chasing
it
yes father
oh heck you broke our bridge how are we
gonna get across
yes we just give up and go back and take
a nap if you're asking me
um split adam i think i have posted
pictures of all of my tattoos before
oh thank you bummer man i appreciate
that also yeah to the people on who
might be on youtube i'm largely reading
twitch chat
just for the record um
so if you want to jump over there it's
where i am reading most of them but
not not reading youtube i'm just mostly
we'll see twitch
wow
it is gold
what are you doing now as guard is up
only fire under arrow
holy fire when i tell you to fire
that makes more sense sorry i thought he
was talking about the stock market sorry
be better i've said that
uh only don't be sorry be better to
people i have uh dated in serious
conversations
100 seriously okay i get that you're
sorry
but just don't do the thing just be
better
um i will turn wherever they are it's
probably
in here ow why does that hurt that's
stupid no
no that's not what i want thank you
though i appreciate it but i'm good
it's not what i'm after i'm after my
settings
which is not here uh is it gonna be this
one
no that's the map um what would settings
be on this that nope still that's the
same button
so i can turn
options there we go the subtitles on
is going to be
audio makes the most sense there we go
all right we've done it
this is gonna hurt me really is i know
it
it is i did put uh for
just full disclosure for anyone who's
seen this game for the first time so
that this isn't a good representation of
it um i am playing on easy so i don't
have to tap as much
so it doesn't hurt me as much as it
could
someone coming from behind me bro go
ahead come on come at me
whoever wants to time
that too this is actually this is
actually okay using the triggers is not
as bad as i thought it would be
so you've never come this close to maybe
i'll be okay keep moving
because i i can no it's gonna hurt me in
the long run who am i kidding
accident was three weeks ago uh
i couldn't use my hand for the first
like week and a half i can use them now
they're still just sore
we're getting there
you went to the old temple but mom told
me never to go in there
we do what we please boy no excuses yes
king
oh thank you leo wow 4am that's crazy
i guess it is 4am i uh my youtube video
editor is in
the uk so can you hit it from here
thank you real wife asaurus we should
get closer
[Music]
i went hunting with mother a bunch of
times you never wanted to take me
why now it was her wish
and it was time it was
time
uh i don't know if it does have well
yeah i should answer questions
i was gonna say i feel like the game
looks real pretty that's why i agree
with
the color looks real nice
i'm trying to get the timing right come
on what's
it's not like i'm really gonna need it
playing the first hour on a stream
there we go
[Applause]
it's way later than i thought
i really should throw it more though
because gosh it's pretty
isn't there a chest around somewhere
i feel like there is maybe i'm
not thinking at the right place
okay
there is bud so it's
uh it's this and then
throw axe
damn right i did son look how cool i am
wonderful we've done it my gosh we've
done it ah there's the chest i was
thinking of
where are you going get cool loop bro
wait this one's locked though isn't it
no okay
what rhymes with alana uh banana
piranha does also rhyme thank you for
the for for asking
zeath i have that problem a lot i know a
lot of people who um
play a lot of video games frequently i
just
so you know i jump between games all the
time i play at least one video game
every day
and i there's this fun game
in figuring out why you're doing
something
like like you're tapping a certain
button or pressing a certain thing and
you're like
what game did i get that from uh i so
often
tap to sprint because of um
gta even if i hadn't played it in a
month
i'll still just tap
now i can do this
good now draw to your chin exit
i got it good
yeah uh translating multiple video game
controls
sure is a wild ride it's
still alive yeah
your knife
[Music]
no finish what you started
can i retroactively take credit for this
game 100 yeah
totally all me
[Music]
i can't
the size of his hands a beast
i just makes me miss my dad
you know
yeah do it robert
[Music]
i'm crying emoji's in the chat
very good oh i'm sorry to the vegan's
present
sorry about that
what's wrong
i mean we could evade but i get that you
don't want to
oh i don't have the axe there we go
get out of here big jerk
completely missed oh oh this fire
oh gosh oh my gosh
critter's gonna get crispy butt
get out of here boss man he's on our
tail get out of here
we're trying to play this game
the music's so good
okay so the recalling of the axe is
hurting my hand more than anything
who'd have thought
[Music]
significant fight
get dunked on mate
who do you think you are i am the god of
war sir
it's wrong
[Music]
look at me look at me boy boy
look at me
[Music]
we did it
all right well time to go home
everything was uh we we've accomplished
everything we set out to accomplish
what nothing in this game could be
harder than that let's go
pack it up i found the deer
i proved myself i have proved myself
how am i not ready we are going home
i haven't been sick yeah roll credits
it's done should you die i have silva
emwin um you are
not it's difficult to maintain is what i
will say
it is quite difficult to maintain
yay things
honestly though oh my god my dad is such
a little softy in comparison it's so
nice
if he were to say do not speak again i'd
be like
what'd you say you all buffed home is
this way
duh thank you i'm trying to collect
things okay
some of us care about collectibles they
get that you just want to keep going
in the same direction but you don't have
well no he does
like you don't have to worry about your
health so
okay
i didn't even read any of that so that's
where i'm at in life boom
axe
hey yeah yeah yeah hello ronnie thank
you for asking i'm doing pretty good
i am good yeah you know i know like
obviously
you know i'm still just indoors um i
might be able to get vaccinated this
month
and i'm pretty stoked about that because
considered priority because of my
health issues um
[Music]
so that's pretty neat i can't open this
yet but he does say something in it
go talk to it boy um but i'm happy
i don't know i've been like quite happy
for the last quiet
i don't know since like mid 2019.
i've been done good even though the
world sucks i am doing good
looking after myself cheering myself up
wait wait wait wait
i can't get up there connie
can i not i'm sure i can
[Music]
i don't remember not that it's been that
long since i played this
have i done any work for sony yet yeah
i've worked there for three
four months
oh thank you clegan i do have more
animated projects coming out
in march i think is the next one um
[Music]
and there are more games i'm doing this
year too um
is it this uh what is it uh uh uh equip
axe is that and then i think it's that
i fully don't know how to do it um i
thought that it was
related to climbing up the thing
um let me hang on there was another
question here that i was halfway to
answer
my american accent's insane uh it's just
very easy for australians to do i think
uh we just don't have any problems doing
it um
the american accent is not so like if i
speak in an american accent oh it
oh it was just circle i don't know why i
thought it was any more complicated than
that
um speaking in an american accent is not
hard for a lot of australians it's sort
of harder when i don't have a script but
uh i i think a lot of people don't
realize that
australian is actually
stupid idiot uh it's like in between
british and american so i intend to just
find it a lot easier to do
my hot taste um a lot of kiwis can do
the accent really well as well
one of these ones is uh they got a trick
to him
i got it that's right i gotta like stomp
in a minute is it gonna
come at me bro your little frost [ __ ]
keep timing it wrong just keep doing it
oh we can put that away and then just
kick the [ __ ] out of you
fame
beautiful just beautiful
you'd love to see it
oh i told you something was different
about the forest and i told you not to
speak
equip acts
just definitely just circle for some
reason i was pressing x
again i don't know what else i played
recently x apparently was climbing
whatever it was
uh the fun house videos you see me and
now from four months ago are you still
guesting on them i'm still guesting on
them
um outside of my work hours i seem very
energetic today
are you dumb ryan this last whole week
like my last stream did it and i'm doing
it in this one um
sorry i should have called you out that
hard i'm sorry i don't know why i did
that
i do not have a lot of energy right now
you can tell when i'm streaming because
i saw that rock grow through the ground
uh i will
forget things very easily
um brain fog
it occurs
he's so speedy just such a fast boy oh
wait is this
maybe i do know exactly what this is
hello
oh thank you
yeah you tell that rock bud you you no
you show it
don't give up you almost had it
what'd you give up for fam
inside boy i didn't recall the axe he
just did it
what are you some kind of god
i don't remember catching myself staring
at his single nipple this much the last
time i played this game but here i am
something wrong with me bonk go to horny
jail or whatever
oh that's a bummer um fenrir uh i'm
finding
sony to be a wonderful company to work
for i'm
really really liking it
i'm glad you asked this question clegane
um that i can answer during this very
emotional part of this game
uh if i had an rpg job role warrior
thief ultra mage etc what would you
choose or what weapons would you love to
use
anyone in any game ever
who does not choose to play a mage slash
wizard fundamentally does not make sense
to me as a person
i can't understand why you would choose
anything other than a wizard
i just i don't get it
nonsensical i there's no point where i
can
relate to why if you have the ability
to use magic to to to conscious spells
to make stuff come out of your hands
that's the most beautiful thing you've
ever seen on a frequent basis
that you would choose to not do that
you know what i'm saying i just don't
get it i don't get it i don't get it
i got beef like if you're like would be
an archer okay just go to an archery
range in your spare time
okay you want to be a ranger you could
do that
now you can't find a class to do in los
angeles on a weekend that will turn you
into a wizard all right
same as any kind of warrior sword
situation you just do that
in real life why would you not be a
wizard
it's nonsensical people stupid that
thing was trying to kill us
it's not like you don't get oh hello
iffy anger can't be a weapon
am i gonna cameo in fun house videos
every now and then um i already have
oh my god i just got a cramp in my butt
a long time oh gosh
i was just trying to get comfortable why
why did this the lord punish me so
um yeah i already i already
already have i don't know what i was
talking about that's the problem just
forget
i want you to try
ow what do you try again
why are you doing that too slow try
again
weak again again
your anger you can get lost in it
without the head is difficult
people with tempers should be careful
quiet
come on out there's no use hiding anyway
buddy
i know who you are he knows me what's
going on
do you know him more important this is
my first time playing this
absolutely not no why beneath the floor
no now
but you told me never to go down there
who is that i do not know
what's he talking about i do not know
get in
yeah he's just a friendly neighbor
stopping by it's nothing to worry about
just tell me what i want to know no need
for this to get bloody okay what do you
want to know fam
do you need to borrow some sugar did you
just move to the neighborhood recently
what can i help you with is it rice what
would you like
i thought you'd be bigger
you should see my dick
long way from home aren't you
what do you want oh
i don't know why i'm like this yeah you
know i don't know why i'm like this
whatever it is you seek i do not how
have i not been canceled already
that's my question you should move on
and here i thought your kind was
supposed to be so enlightened and so
much
better than us so much this is a
wonderful
you performance out here in the woods
like a coward
what specifically is cowardly about
hiding out in the woods i'm
pretty sure wouldn't it be easier to be
in a city
i feel like leave
not that cowardly overall
it's real cold out here bro you
are going to have to kill me for that to
happen that's going to be a problem
this game's so
i good you finally
i like to think he showed up as some
part of a kink you would not listen
you just really wanted to get stepped on
it's like all of us with
uh tall vampire lady
you just show up at a house and like
what's up queen that said when i found
out that she was
like nine feet um
it did concern me a little bit i am
going to be scared of her
9-6 right they said that today which is
very cool like i thought it was a really
neat thing for them to
to update us on uh
if she's chasing me you know how like
jack does in resident evil 7 i was so
scared
i hate being chased in video games
um because i am really a coward with
horror games of consent
oh i was supposed to dodge that and i
pressed the wrong button
uh if she is is
that many feet and ends up chasing us
i'm gonna like need somebody else to
play that part of that game for me it's
gonna it really is gonna
are you even trying
no but maybe there's no chase sequence
maybe it's all just combat and
it's just a great time but that fight
with jack where he's like following you
around in a circle with
a uh not chainsaw but sort of damaged
[Music]
terrifying terrifying a lot of it
and there's like the whole first house
he just chases you oh god that first
house is good
not that resident evil 7 isn't good top
to bottom but the part where it gets to
the boat was where it really lost me but
man that first house and jack
buster the wall really good stuff
sometimes i like to bring [ __ ] home
but i'm afraid of emotions
so i don't let them cuddle me and i give
them their own bed all right
okay that's why there are two bits all
right i don't like affection
it makes me uncomfortable
you can't just ask someone that kind of
question
struck a nerve did i
[Music]
now we cool compressor come on you
trying to play
i love how early into this game this
fight happens
it is the most dragon ball z thing ever
i narrate the best walkthrough to be
clear this whole thing this whole time
i'm playing this i don't know
how much longer i've played for i wasn't
gonna play for a seat long time ago
stupid hands
um watch because i don't want to make
any actual comments on the game
it is all going to be stupid jokes
so
that's what you've signed up for i'm
sure literally the opposite of people
why people would want to watch they'll
be like oh interesting somebody who
walks there is uh playing the game in
the stream well maybe we can get some
info and i'm like ah he got two beds
because he [ __ ] [ __ ] and won't
cuddle them after
no i'm so sorry
[Music]
it's just the lost girl
i went down on and i just don't feel
like you need to know about it
okay i don't i also just didn't really
want to confront this today
this is not you know uh i was hoping to
talk to my therapist about this in our
next session
and the fact that you've grown up
prematurely means that i as an
emotionally stunted uh god of war
um was not prepared to deal with this
content and you know it takes me a long
time to break through those barriers so
okay that's what i'm hiding my fear of
being loved
all right
the record this is none of this is a
parallel for me i'm like
very fond of affecting a very
affectionate person
only with the people i'm dating that
won't hug a stranger all that often
or even like a friend but in a
relationship loves a cuddle
that's what you get so good though
so good gosh
i'm playing on easy twisted the easiest
of difficulties
while i am still in recovery mode i
think i'll be fine in about two weeks
the problem is controllers um mouse is
sucked too but
it's just that it pushes up against the
parts that i saw in my palms
yeah i haven't been able to play a lot
the medium was working pretty well
because it's not all that interactive i
could do that for a while i just needed
answers but you you
i want you to know one thing
i can't feel any of this
that would be pretty devastating
you're beating the crap out of someone
and they're like by the way invincible
and i can't feel it
okay bye you feel like well
hurt that's nothing can this fight is
pointless you know what could hurt you
what if i started to roast you i think
the beads in your beard are stupid
i think you look dumb and i think
your eyes are too blue
did that hurt you can't
win i feel
nothing but you you stop insulting him
critics go
go for digs tell him he's not even
as pretty as his brother tell him
everyone thinks his brother is way
scarier he'll hate that
tell him tell him odin doesn't even like
him tell him go
he's gonna hate it and then he'll leave
maybe then he can go back to
slaying puss
i wonder why i'm playing so defensively
maybe it is that like last time i played
i didn't play on easy but
like i'm really just waiting for them
it's either that or i played something
else that requires you to be defensive
recently
i'm not sure
you definitely didn't feel that because
i was not locked onto you
i really like the jewel sense i'm a
really big fan
i feel like some games the haptic
feedback is like a bit much and i'm like
damn okay
chill out but um
generally i really like it
what if this is what he wanted would
finally make me feel
something but you can't this isn't
working for you
think your beard beads suck see that's
how we took him out in the end
you think you're a big physical tough
guy
insult a man's beard all right
see how tough he is you know what i'm
saying it's not gonna last
kratos definitely could take mcgregor
yeah but could he take logan paul
that's my question
was he he knew me
did he know my past how did they
find me after all this time
faye what do i do
our son is not ready
to carry your ashes to the top mountain
maybe he's born with it
[Music]
and neither am i
i do not know how to do this without you
i'm sorry for all the fun i'm making of
you great taste i'm a really big fan
um and this is also very sad
but
you know but we cannot stay
exactly that's what i but we cannot stay
here that's what i meant to say
so would be funnier kratos said but
you know
boy there was so much
i i thought
you're all right i am all right
come on
gather your things will i fight the
valkyries i'm probably not gonna do that
i don't think my hands would like that
very much
[Music]
you are not um we have no choice now but
i did when i first put it
prove me wrong yes sir
yes sir thank you sir i called my dad so
he'd slap me about
it's to be a long trip disclosure bias
whatever but an important one you know
how it is
how did this happen
you know just
i took a nap and then i woke up and i
yawned and i shattered the earth
there was nobody here you don't you
didn't see anything
or nobody's did you kill him
i did what had to be done
that alludes to him being dead oh i
guess okay no it makes sense
it makes sense never leave me alone
again
right bit clingy mate
oh you've had to kill people before
haven't you
you're used to it we do what we must to
survive
animals i get their food
driver they're supposed to be dead but
people they're trying to survive too
close your heart to it on our journey we
will be attacked by
all manner of creature close your heart
to their desperation
close your heart to their suffering do
not allow yourself to feel for them
ray will not feel for you i understand i
think i agree to an extent
i think that it's has this been here all
this time
there are lays you know you know what
i'm saying why don't you hold me up
there
okay buddy
you need a little boost because you're a
little squat
any opinion on what's happening with the
series x i don't know what's happening
with sirius x
almost nobody with a console on the east
coast of canada is it just hard to get
one
um
yeah i don't know what's what's going on
with the video game news
because i don't need to it's great uh
i don't feel like that was what i was
supposed to do here
and i don't think i can oh what's that
what is this
what is hello i feel
i sure can mate thanks for asking
made it give chain
boy yes sir
and then i'll be wanting to equip the
axe
is what i would like to do
didn't name that correctly at all
yeah the scalpel stuff really sucks i
you know i buy shoes
um i'm a person who
buys sneakers uh it's a real problem
um to the extent where there are people
that i know who just
got bots so they can compete with the
bots just to be regular consumers who
can do it
sucks so bad an offering mother said
odin's disciples fill them with gifts
and hang them where thieves can't reach
them
that one looks really old come on now
worshiping the gods gods care nothing
for them
men should not pray to monsters
that's true in a lot of cases too how
are you gonna get across now
what was the question there any more
charity streams in the works my last
charity stream was the last time i
streamed i did consider doing this one
for charity too
um
uh yeah i've already done um i think
five charity streams this year
the truth is that i will probably make
it a thing that if slash when i partner
on twitch which i think i will do
virtually every stream is for charity uh
that's sort of the plan
well it's so pretty out there you know
um okay
i gotta go back i gotta come back yeah i
know
i know i know uh okay i can't do it this
way no i'm gonna go back down i think
um but yes generally one charity stream
a week is how we do it
not necessarily on my own channel
um but i do always advertise them
somewhere at least so do i believe in
god
wow we're really getting we're really
going places
uh i don't did you see those hands-free
nike shoes from the other day
so yeah i did those those new nikes that
lace themselves
um so cool
um i'm definitely not into them but um
in terms of oh that's right i always
forget you have to look at it father
yes sir we see others on the road yes
friendly no try and rob us
possibly yes yeah they i i wouldn't
wear them i don't like the style but in
terms of accessibility they're they're
so neat the fact that they like lace
themselves up is just so cool it's such
a cool step to take it's like super
exciting
um rick for rick james four
yes
it's beautiful
look all this time
there's been a protection stave around
our entire woods
but the stave is broken there
did you cut those down what time is it
right now
i had a friend just invite me to a thing
on clubhouse
but i probably want that why do i keep
changing
chairs and headsets i don't
just the two and if it's a different one
it's because i'm in a different place
i'm not swapping them out in my own
apartment
uh that i'm just in a literally
different location which is why both
things are different
and why the microphone is also different
it seems so simple you know
what
friend do you want no actually jeff
keely and aaron greenberg one of the
friends
uh i have not finished the medium no not
yet for winter falls
yeah i can't do a lot of video games
playing and i've been working
they don't see us
oh heck not my son
i should have probably done that but i
was committed
to pressing r2 so here we are
oh
beautiful thank you
i'm too far right damn it chair in the
way there's nothing i can do about that
i should put the webcam
not yet not right now
hey i totally dodged how dare you
[Music]
big stupid jack
[Music]
you're also a big stupid joke oh he's
still got a tiny bit of alpha
should i let her try to do that
move out of the way kid
[Music]
that's where you got a quick turn
i see i see i see
i don't think i'm nimble enough quite
yet to be quick turning
you're doing this stuff and cut oh no
that hurts now we're not doing any of
that distract them
whoever read this what'd it say child
only when safe to do so
i can do that nikki boy over here
there's a yetna settlement giants
you can read the writing some god could
quick turn like that
but they're all sort of connected so
sometimes i can feel my way through
stuff i shouldn't know
you know
let me move my camera to the other side
because i feel like the way that i'm
sitting makes more sense if i'm over
here too
there we go look at it less invasive
oh we've done it 40 beautiful
[Music]
makes my flask so damn large gotta drink
a lot of water man
zodiac killer drink a lot of water
are you a big [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're just not paying attention uh put
away
and punch in face
he just really came up and hit the god
of war and i was like dang
anything else special shots i really
want to replay darksiders
i never finished three and i was so
excited about that game it's like
don't know why i didn't think there was
a reason i don't know what it was
it was something that stopped me from
playing it
oh thank you
i don't have any though anyway no
quite sure i don't
i'm the god of war son all right you'll
get used to it
you know what i'm saying move thanks
dark side is 2 is underrated
look i do really like that game but
here's my beef with darksiders too it's
fine
the latter hop of that game the
environments is just so
similar um at the start it's really
different when you have that bit that's
in the um
big water plants i don't know what it
would actually be called
uh my favorite song ever isn't that game
kratos you're way too thick to be doing
this kind of recon my dude
what did you know way too thick
oh heck that wasn't so bad slow
down your haste will cost us
sorry whoa i realize that my stripe
the green stripe of the playstation is
gone
but these aren't moving amazing are they
definitely a cool shot though
more dead boy
the dark side of soundtrack is really
good uh yes but kid i believe
how did i get the ps5 from best buy
remember accuracy over speed
[Music]
yeah i i said this on twitter the other
day but
i was just at a point where i was so
careful about everything i said because
people get so upset so
um everyone i know bought a uh
uh a ps5 um the regular way oh
dodge dodge dodge quick
um and that's not to say that it's not
difficult and all that stuff
that's not what i'm trying to say i know
that scalpers are a problem
um just it was like a note
everyone i know just bought it managed
to get it at the right time
a friend maybe bought two and they got
an extra one like that kind of stuff
get ruined
good day sir you should we mess up
everybody to some sport
oh thank you
ah sony sent you an email asking if you
wanted to pre-order one look at this
i got mine um
a lot of folks thought working at
somewhere like ideon helps your chances
oh hey mark hey what's up
yeah i don't know how that would help
though
mark uh i worked with an ig and he said
i bought mine at target like everyone
else yeah
mine was the best buy order like
everyone else it's not like best buy was
like hmm
a lot of pierce let's get her one that
definitely didn't happen you did
oh this used to be a marketplace the
giants used to gather here to trade with
the gods a long time ago
i wonder if one was over here
something's breaking through the wall oh
no
oh gosh
um but yes again not trying to the best
way to stop vip light for influencers
then for me uh yeah again not trying to
pretend that it's
not a problem um
yeah i know a lot of people who made it
work somehow
i love it when you can get multiple of
them probably not
this one
oh yeah i've not been using the the
spartan rage
look there's an opening up there cool
let's go do you hear that
it's just my throat it's me don't worry
about it stay
close
what
these headphones are so good you know
microsoft windows headphones
the direction oh okay jack of these uh
these are so neat with that audio
is very good
that's right you gotta do it you do it
and then i do it
and then we do it
get out of here you haul it
no i cannot answer any questions about
ragnarok but thank you for asking
uh
every cheese like that oh yeah you can
well okay
like i'm not playing on hard um but
using the arrows uh and rock throws
axe throws with the i don't understand
why that man attacked you at our house
uh i told you boys i know nothing more
of it super helpful
have i seen elven ring no of course not
look up there i guess we need to get
back up there
but how follow me i don't even know if
that thing exists yet
it's a beauty of video games they don't
exist until they kind of do it takes a
while
but like that sentence is truer than you
think it is they don't exist until
like like two weeks before they come out
they're completely fake
made up but not real
why not you know why not not the ideal
place to use it but
sometimes i just want to beat the pants
off of someone
and here's what we're going to do just a
bit of a waste
but a fun waist a fun waist can i
explain how i injured my hands
sure um i was trying not to
give too much detail but uh i was in a
motorbike accident
it's the
[Music]
i would like this
i've seen this language before
okay let's go
i had him like kitted out by the time i
finished this game dressing kratos up in
fancy clothes
was wildly unexpected at the time
these environments sure are still really
pretty
so much color in this game too it's real
nice i'm a fan
i'm a fan in case you couldn't already
tell
are we lost are you lost
sass me i'm your dad
i'm gonna i brought myself a coke out
here i'm just gonna open that real quick
too
you know pulling out all the beverages
today wouldn't
wouldn't be one of my streams if i
didn't have seven veg beverages
available
yeah it does suck to open stuff though
we make it work i had a fight with an
orange juice bottle the other day and
the orange juice bottle won
i gave up i could not open it
it was too strong for me my weak kids i
couldn't
have to give up on it it was very sad
one day i'll beat you orange juice
bottle
but today's not that day
okay
where are they all is that one
what's that over there that one where's
the third one it might be in that room
you know
i'm not positive
oh is this one not timed no it's not
those are the bell ones
come on i'm the god of war i can throw
that far
earlier you said people might try and
rob us i'll kill them
i'm not afraid oh if we encounter them
we got a batman over here
i don't know get me i can fight you will
stay out of it boy
speak no more of this
there it is
i recognize what that noise means but
i'm just going to open this chest real
quick don't mind me
good day good day
such a beautiful music
with a voice like that kratos would do
you would do whatever kratos told you to
yeah pretty much same
i agree gum grumpy goron
uh yes gamestop that is correct i can't
do much with my hands they are getting
better every day
it's a healing process
i feel like we're talking about it quite
a bit
um i thought that might be the case
i know it's not this simple and i don't
remember what it is
what's up [ __ ]
[Music]
beat your ass up
and
okay love
hey buddy hi buddy's friends
i was hoping i could keep it in the air
the whole time i love an aerial combo i
loved what um
miles morales and i guess spider-man in
general spider-man ps4 does it too
did with the aerial combo stuff it's so
much fun to watch in in
anything that's not a fighting game not
that it's not fun in fighting games too
but
it just gets next level and other stuff
for sure
you did it is that what happens this one
no i don't remember
but i feel like i should let it go
it's not like i'm trying to get
completion levels on this thing
for this stream
okay
all these dead you think it's safe in
there you think it's safer out here
anyone else when they first played this
game see how long they could leave the
axe full
because i definitely did
hell walkers they're untouched look
someone start the fires sigmund you're
nice
so many days without meat
wait us behind me what if they change
like the others
we'll have to keep them alive strip off
their meat
this fight hey boys
beat you all up get absolutely dunked on
every single one of you you trying to
eat my son
you eat my fists
okay bye
you could have asked before giving me a
hug
atreus
boy he fine he just napping
he's got a human blanket
sorry buddy i tried i really did try
to do all of it i'm sorry
close your heart to it
but not to everything i feel like maybe
father should clarify that
you close your heart to a lot of things
but not to everything because
that could lead to some trauma later in
life
there's some things wait here
i will handle this
i'm definitely not doing them enough
that's so cool what is happening to my
phone
he keeps forgetting that it's connected
and then panicking when it realizes it
is connected
really having some trouble
i don't know why i'm doing this this way
i'm just like one head at a time could
be fun
just really not
they necessary back the shitty came back
they came back they just finished they
did
i want to leave here then collect
yourself
we must find a way out
i do feel sorry for him it is quite sad
it is quite sad
did bruce get a dog is that what you're
telling me scooterman gaming
they've not said anything to me but they
did get their dog
i know autumn was like posting like
stories about it
oh my gosh and i am yeah
i knew it was like today but i wasn't
positive or it seemed oh it's on stream
right now okay oh my gosh
is it a puppy what kind of puppy can you
tell me about it
gosh predict a bruce raid
at the end of this at the end of what of
my stream so for the record the way that
i tend to do stuff
is i pick whichever one of my friends
has the least amount of viewers
which does mean that i don't um
frequently raid bruce uh not by any
fault of bruce's
um
just because he always has a lot of
viewers so oh that's right
boy that is where he's supposed to go
right
yeah come on kiddo get your butt out
here
can you do this for me you deal with
this situation for me please
you little emo kid atreus the chain
okay oh thank you genten i appreciate it
you are in your head boy let it go
he would have killed you
i do know and give me this dang chain
and we will go home boy what to give up
this easily
so close to the start wait no
i'm not giving up i can do this phone
can you stop freaking out you know
catch my breath just chill would you
please come on up
i'm ready
okay yeah butts
i've played zelda
all right listen to me to be effective
yeah well welcome
uh darth vader not feel voiceless the
road ahead is long
oh it's not my phone's fault that it
keeps turning on boy
you must be a warrior it's uh just my
connector cable
is what's actually having the panic
attack
pots
chest
come on already let's go
[Music]
stop
i keep thinking somebody's calling me
i'm just gonna unplug it i should do
that this slow like [ __ ] hunk to cross
the bridge
it's because she's scared of something
in the trees over there there's what now
father throw your axe at those trees on
the other side of the bridge
okay with the white trunks
bastard never asked mine swain ever
asked hers
what's yours
[Music]
say uh you're not gonna believe me
but that axe you got
it was me what mater me and my brother
was one of our best so don't let nobody
else go work on herself for us
too you gotta handle her special
or she'll wreck beyond fixing
i can enhance her for you right now if
it so pleases you son of a [ __ ]
so what's saying you are right
i do not believe you come boy
trying to see if i have an asthma puffer
real quick there's a rune in the shape
of a fork under the grip
i don't think they do i don't think i do
not that i need it desperately i'll be
fine that was our brand my brother and
me before we split
i got half of it right here see
look you want to sit up crater or not
yeah do it king
very well very well i expect an
improvement
could not be more different to the way
that i just said that
ah thank you fenrin
i'm not 100 back yet i still got wraps
on my hand
okay but i got all the talent
look
now you're talking
beautiful
lovely i've not seen bruce's new puppy
yet no
let me check like autumn's social media
real quick
i'm sure she's posted something
oh oh my gosh she's so
cute oh that's a very cute puppy
oh my gosh
oh i want a dog so bad
uh huh
oh you make up your mind
[Music]
we can do that we
yeah i agree micro i think the character
walks really good in this
i need to organize the time to go pat
the new puppy i would but covered
um it got worse you know there are times
that i've seen
well don't look now but our friends and
lawrence
maybe twice since go on give that action
in the last 12 months not much um
but it's just so bad in l.a right now
that
i don't think i could do that safely
yeah i did see bruce twice i think well
maybe three times
um i guess i will be tested in a couple
of weeks
for a thing so maybe we could time that
out i don't know
but it is just not a great idea right
now unfortunately
to really see anyone
the new star wars video got nostalgic uh
if you mean the fun house one
yeah well um i'm streaming with um
with uh john and jacob on friday i think
we're gonna do
that's not like fully set in stone quite
yet but
yeah i still make content with those
guys all the time that's not
a thing that has stopped you left me to
fight alone
i did people are one thing everything
else you fight
until i say stop or we are dead
understand
pull your way to we go home i understand
i want to delete the axe
can you take that
yeah you're right kid we can
sometimes i just want to abandon the axe
you know what i'm saying
what's this what's this what's this hmm
is it through the middle it's inviting
i don't recall
ah it's through this one um
oh push it the whole way i'm a genius
cool thanks
this game is very good i agree
i did see the puppy phil dog
i have seen the puppy i have not seen it
on stream but i have seen the puppy
uh what part of l.a do i live in
definitely prefer not to answer that
it'd be cool if for god of war 2 you can
do a no axe run or something
said the j i may have had insider info
on how to open that door that is a good
point
i may have oh look at his it's all
rainbow
that's so cute oh my god
oh gosh time that terribly
good day
thank you later it's like i really
appreciate you helping me out from a
fall that's real nice
but i'm good dude i got it i am
literally kratos
the god of war but thanks
no can you just let me get this out damn
it where is he where is he where is he
where is he where is he
you can do it you little nerd they only
want me
you'll be fine
get him this is definitely not how this
is supposed to be done i don't think
come on bud get him get him yeah look at
you go
[Laughter]
i'm proud of you kid look at you're
doing it i'm not doing anything
just take the first one out first all
right can we position
[Applause]
well no that's right he can't
i gotta actually finish them i think
is the rules
punch you in the face too i don't care
you know my dad do whatever i want beefy
boy
correct all right
that's what we want to do we're scared
over my head and there we go
follow me okay by what
literally what in here could have
distracted you
brats man um
i have to move that thing right that's
what i'm supposed to do yeah
yeah yeah yeah now that the combat is
done
it is recall axe it's coming back down
again
where's am i just supposed to jump
across i don't remember
okay
so i missed it it's supposed to be that
one okay
recall grow dammit
and then we can destroy that oh i could
just throw it in this one as well connie
there are totally
more than just this way to do this but
maybe that was the right way to do it
if i'm being perfectly honest that you
did have to do it multiple times but i
want to throw that one and then whatever
it's done the work is done uh this
this that's all right
we'll be okay i'm like super tough
um there's something up here if i recall
have i played return of the oberdin i
have jordan
i really like that game
um how do i get you and the entire
roosty team and i guess now all of
santa monica studios go to my wedding
also you can dj mostly benson i need
benson there
um well we're going to get out of there
all of rooster
will not let us die and all of santa
monica studios
has got to be like a thousand people
so
money it'd just be a lot of money i
think is the
genuine answer to how you would do that
um quite an expensive wedding
i do really want to dj uh you know a
someone who knows who i am's wedding at
some point though
i feel like that would be so much fun um
but it is a matter of
not having being able to find me there
doing all the
the pre-work and me being able to do it
having the availability to do it but i
feel like it would be a good time ah
damn it
this way no it's not this way hey that
could be valuable
you don't say kid
we're trying to open and crash your
laptop hard that seems
unfortunate where is the last one though
i don't need to do this the whole way
where are you
final seal
where your punk ass at
hmm i don't remember oh it's there
take me back down king get me to that
chest
a wedding on new year's eve fuzzy
brother that seems nuts i'm really
hurting my own knee right now
damn it damn it damn it damn it i'm just
trying to get to the lake
and then i figured i would stop
thank you for horn of blood mead
again exact same spot i keep thinking
there's like a platform there
that's not
wow never been this close to the
mountain before
it looks so big pretty big mountain
it's fair i wish mom was here to see it
it's true that she never saw a mountain
it do be a mountain though
oh boy
let's go
that's pretty that's real pretty
there's like some red bull um
screenshot thing happening right now i
don't really know the details of them
exactly
we partnership with sony i think it just
seems really cool um
what does it say i wish i could give you
more info i don't
really follow it but i think it's like a
competition of people to submit
screenshots from
playstation games maybe there's a clue
around here
i also love god of war real dan job is
great thank you
real good um
angelino this game came out a long time
before
red dead redemption 2. this game came
out in april
of 2018 and then red dead came out in
the latter half of the year
um
so i feel like that one's on you you
know
all right let's do it then
any streaming with markiplier or ethan
this year
i'm sure i will i have no doubt ethan is
one of my best friends
so um
making content with him is a given and a
pleasure
that you could freeze yeah i know you
punk
i'm just slow just way way too slow
get that one all right oh
do it in the correct order uh it's just
got to be the right way up i think
that and then what does it stay that way
or will it keep
no no no i get it i get it i get it
dude okay yeah yep i understand i i
i i've solved the problem but i gotta
wait for it to get
the whole way back over or is it on this
side
what what should the top look like
this could be wrong what i'm about to do
still doesn't look like anything no i
think that yo
you are right kid you are right
okay
the middle part is still incorrect
gotcha
just flip it you just do a cute little
flip
my gosh we've done it that's it i see
rooms
what they say boy what do those runes
say
oh it says
the only time i'm playing video games
right now is on stream um
no that's not true
really but uh no i think i'll i will
play more of it on stream um
something happened it's nice playing a
scary game on stream because it's
comforting
but yeah i just kind of use my hands
right now i'm sorry i'm sure this is
really boring for me to keep retreading
um i appreciate that that you guys care
that's very nice
uh the voice of kratos is chris judge
oh yeah i love the mousepad jeff um he
said your audio
mousepad from the unboxing is really
cool i put it over the top of my razor
mouse pad so
it doesn't get grossly dirty again um
uh rockstar sent me it was a christmas
gift from
my friends at rockstar
i was having a conversation with someone
recently where i was saying
the only other game studio i can imagine
working for other than santa monica
studio
at this point um unless it was an indie
studio would be rockstar
boy these tracks
a boar maybe what you know working
conditions apparently
but i i love their approach too it is
important for a warrior to keep
right
oh gosh big troll
be ready what do i take in my coffee
um nothing
just milk really big jack
no thank you
not anymore sometimes you just throw
your freezy axe at the fire
and the fire go out i recall it too fast
it was me get the one off disney at
least
if i do that right
good day i said good day
i do remember finding this fight hard
because the first time i played this
game i did played on the hardest
difficulty
this one i feel like was the first time
that i was like oh
i've got a video game on my hands huh
get out of here brennan
no you don't no you don't no you don't
no you don't
[Music]
doing a lot of damage to him you know
either way really is the truth
see it hunk
uh mr trigger in santa monica studio
made the old you gotta walk in
oh thank you thick boy a very nice
comment from a very strange username i
appreciate that thank you
i feel like um anytime a stranger says
they're proud of my journey i don't find
it weird because i feel like my
journey's been very public
um and i'm absolutely not an overnight
success it's been a
uh a public very very slow what does it
say
this is a timed one yeah um very slow
process
to get where i'm at today and i think
i've been very vocal about that process
because i've just been trying to
help people where i can and give advice
where i can
i know there is an easier way to do this
one
where is the third one i think you have
to be higher to get it if i remember
correctly
i don't remember where it is maybe up
here
we could keep going it's cool i don't
mind
boy
do chain thank you yes king appreciate
you
boy you can do it all from here huh
interesting not positive
that's where it is no that's the same
one i really don't remember
i don't know oh gosh
uh it's fine alana stop trying to
complete the video game that you have
already completed
it's not necessary uh which way do we
come from i'm gonna go up this way here
we go
why do i stream to multiple platforms um
the the reason and again i think i am
going to partner on twitch
uh is because i i you know spent years
building an audience on youtube and it
just
seemed shitty that um i would just leave
them
uh and also i think buying into
exclusivity sucks um
for a lot of people
um the reason i'm thinking
about doing it though is because twitch
has just
so much better tools for it
um and i think that i can also use it in
a very beneficial way for
a lot of the charity work that i've been
doing where you know that money could go
to charities
all the time supposed to go up here not
likely i don't think so
let me just believe
um but yeah that's the gist
it's also that uh like right now i have
more viewers on twitch that i have on
youtube it's 900 on youtube and just
over a thousand on twitch so
the tipping point was kind of when
twitch for streaming purposes overtook
youtube
and also youtube chat can be really
toxic and uh shitty because
every streamer i know says that about it
it's a really consistent experience for
a lot of people am i going backwards
right now
i'm not sure i might be
i am yeah okay
um whereas twitch chat tends to be much
friendlier
so yeah what would i rate this game 10
out of 10
purchase it immediately no i'm just a
joke
you don't want to ask me to rate this
game
um i'm a big fan here's my genuine
answer
big fan but also work for the studio
boy are you your animal ahead i knew it
was a boy
do with that information i thought you
will
don't please don't be more toxic it's
really nice
that is true
what do you think it looked weirder than
any board i've ever seen
get after it then take a shot every time
grotesque says boy
do i have any platinum trophies i have a
number yeah
a few my trophies are private though um
i actually keep my entire playstation
account
private more of those people uh and i
have four of them
stupid reasons um
oh hey odin uh but
some of the bodies of those weird dead
things
um my xbox live is still totally public
and
i take uh
game invites on them sometimes i stream
with people on there i just keep that to
xbox
specifically because um i like the way
they handle the privacy services for
people like me
the following system and the messaging
system are all
very cool they must have been fighting
it's so pretty when i went away for
christmas
jesus genuinely showed up
um it was just so nice to get like fresh
air in the woods
oh my gosh
he had no right to be that scary that
was rude i
got i got words to say to you corey i
got we got beef
you caught you did that to me just now
yeah who do you think you are
what a dick you know i got it director
ridiculous steady hand
ryan i'm also really excited for little
nightmares too that comes out this month
in like a couple of weeks right
do not lose it i am very excited about
that game i will
surely stream that one um yeah i loved
the
the first one really really really
enjoyed that game
video games are just so good is the
thing the variety
of the video games that we're talking
about here
my gosh what a great medium where are
you
i think i'd like to make one huh
wait for me boy
the dress thank you to the person who
put in a combo suggestion but listen
i'm gonna be real we're not getting
fancy with anything here today
it's not it's not happening
i really do think i'll be okay in a
couple of weeks they're getting better
every single day it's just the bottom of
my palms are still really sore on both
sides and i like
like double wrapped this one he doesn't
he's my friend he's just
whatever it's uninteresting i'm sorry
then help fix this
hello please hold i said he's losing
blood
the last of his kind and all the realm
and you shoot him you needed food
target practice target practice
i'm i'm so so sorry keep that pressure
on the blame is mine should have kept a
closer eye
will he die i will not let him you
the arrow cut a tight way inside him
find both ends and hold them tightly
start with the left side grab it and
hold
now the right side hold it tight her um
voice actress is so lovely
i think i met her at the dice awards
where they
where they won won so many awards that
year in 2018.
she's um just so enthusiastic and so
cool you're really nice
you're a witch i can't finish the
healing here
my home is just beyond the trees there
you will carry him
he must not die i might have met her at
the game at once but she was also
enticed
good not that that's interesting to
anyone either
you know yeah danielle what's up
she's very nice and she is a babe that
is also true but mostly that she's
incredibly cool
isn't she tall yeah she is tall i think
she might be around my height though
she did wear heels most of the time when
i see her but i feel like she's not that
much taller than me
it's so pretty that bow is a little big
for you isn't it
my mother made it for me um chris judge
was also a dice always had a
conversation with him he was also
awesome
being away from home i wonder if that
was my first dice i don't remember all i
know is my first dice i
we're taking her ashes to the high
school very drunkenly
um i walked up to a dev that i'm a huge
fan of
i just spoke to him for ages about
persona and the fact that
i did that as someone who's really
introverted overall and like doesn't go
and just speak to people
just drunk and that he like that he
doesn't hate me is great
no he's a friend now which is very nice
could have gone way worse
but he definitely remembered the
interaction the next time i saw him
oh gosh
is he friendly
boy i'm nine six i'm not
lady demuskira or however it is that you
say her name i'm five foot ten
no the person i walked up to was not uh
not an employee of santa monica studios
i could probably be moving faster but it
was heavy man
quickly
place him on the stave there okay
keep him still a lot of demands coming
from you love what are you doing
you know okay all right do you know who
i am
oh my gosh it's better this way
yeah my father doesn't like people
either boy well
you don't hold him still before he hurts
he wasn't wrong
good
easy rest looks like i've dropped frames
but i'm not sure oh no i'm okay i need
two more things
fresh red root grows just behind the
house can you told me that i had but it
seems to be a lie
what else
i i do like that she still takes the
effort to do her eye shadow every day
i know you're a god not of this realm
but there's no mistaking it
he doesn't know does he about your true
nature
or his own that is none of your concern
the gods of these realms don't take
kindly to outsiders trust me i know
when they find you and they will
they'll make them of already have if
we're being honest boy will want answers
that will be my problem whatever you're
hiding you cannot protect him forever
but you're right doesn't concern me
i like a cape i also need lamb's crafts
do you mind
it's a white petal flower in my garden
just a handful
she pours without even looking what a
boss
and here we continue the trend of having
old man characters collect white flowers
just like uh ezio or tori de ferenza
and assassin's creed revelations as i
like to call him aldzia
there's like literally a side quest in
that game it might not even be a side
quest it could be a
main quest it might be you know fish
um where you go collect flowers
and it's just so lovely just the
loveliest thing
i really did love that that old man that
old boy
hello lambscraft good
have you the red root as well the boy is
searching yes
perhaps he could use help please the sav
is nothing without i better be getting
paid for this
just trying to eat all right
wait a minute ridiculous
jesus
get out of here nerd you're so weak god
why am i like this i don't just insult
everything well i know why i like this
it's because i'm australian
you know it's just it's a consistent
thing we have going on
what's wrong with me if i
if i lost it then you did lose it
i'll take better care of it from now on
it did belong to your mother treating it
that way is
pretty messed up just a blatant
disregard
feed that mom like my mom sends me a
card and i
i keep it forever i'm like she wrote on
it with her own hands
it's perfect oh my gosh and he's like
well i'm just cool whatever
that's exactly what i need grandma sent
me a postcard recently
and it asks all these questions and i'm
like how does she think i'm gonna reply
so he's gonna live i could text her yes
but i guess i'll send a postcard back
and we'll just communicate in three
months chunks of time
she's like how's work why would you not
say how you are in a postcard why are
you asking me questions
what do you want me to do with this but
thank you
you want solitude this mark will hide
you from
those who might make your journey
difficult
am i gonna pick up valhalla it's so good
to all they see lol fans
hey maybe eventually i don't think i
will
i think i've just played there's a
shortcut below the house that leads
safely um follow this path just too many
assassins creeds is
sort of how i feel you know and there's
so many games that i want to get through
will we see you again
as much or as little as you like now get
out of here
the rom is really cool
okay this underground passage should put
you back on your path to the mountain
thank you just use the boat we'll do
wait
and take this you can use it to orient
yourself
it will always steer you towards your
goals that makes more sense
thank you for the witches compass which
are the woods
so weak they just look like big buggers
you
you clearly don't wish you could oscar
that bad you lost her knife
so i actually will get to them ted
really liked assassin's creed origins
i feel like for me personally i know
people loved odyssey and i did play a
little bit odyssey i've not played any
of them
um when i played one of them i didn't
feel the need to play more of them
because they're also so long
um
there's the mountain there's the
flow into mountains water how do you
know so yeah i guess like while i really
liked origins as a game
by itself uh i gave it a nine out of ten
for ign i really enjoyed it
um i just didn't look at that
it's thor this is where i was going to
end it you guys
that's right i just uh i thought you
listened when mother spoke with the gods
didn't feel the need to keep playing
with that and they do change it every
time
it's gonna be hard to make that but
didn't feel they need to keep playing
them
son of odin and free and odin is king
that's right why do you ask
i see rooms there miss chest what'd they
say
it reads sacrifice your arms to the
center of the water
awaken again the cradle of the world
it's so good it's just so good
throw our weapons into the water guess
that won't be a problem for you
are you gonna do it
stream looks better on twitch yeah
youtube compression really ruins things
a lot of the time
the axe did not return
it's cool you made a friend
what is this
it's the eye of sauron oh sorry it was
heaven
i'm pretty happy with how well i timed
me and
atreya saying that at the same time i'm
going to be honest
thank you stay close
oh yeah this is great
[Music]
i love him
i just want to give him a hug you know
that was amazing can you give him a nice
hug
wait there's a shipwreck way over there
see that
and there's a statue of thor except i
can see a lot more of him now
the water dropped when the serpent rose
oh that must be why the beach wasn't
there before see
and there's the mountain look it that
building leads from the foot of the
mountain to that golden temple
this game rules it's all just under the
surface except for the statue
good thing huh there's even a dock there
next to the flag
all right swim then punk get going we're
going to the dock first right
i am we'll be the first people to walk
on and who knows
you know of that serpent he's one of the
giants
he's so big he's wrapped around the
whole world and bites his own tail
an exaggeration
the whole world though i mean he is
pretty big
big cutie just a really large puppy
you know um i'm gonna leave it there
though you guys
i'm gonna leave it here this game
absolutely rules
and i love it
um robo rojo boyo tell you is the shirt
you're wearing something that can be
purchased yeah
i wouldn't know what details to give you
it was
one of the anniversary shirts but yes
you can
buy it um
more when i probably won't play this
game and i just wanted to do this today
uh
because playing it on stream is
you know just a lot of people
asking for details about the upcoming
video
games which i i want to avoid you guys
are really great about it though thank
you i appreciate it everyone appreciate
you um
being cool about it is it bedtime
not quite yet it's only 9 30 uh austin
but bedtime pretty soon but yeah
i'll hopefully stream a little bit more
of the medium
um uh definitely planning to stream on
friday
with john and jacob don't know what
we're playing yet he might done spelunky
or something
but uh yeah
thanks for joining me everyone
see you guys next time